china said on monday that married
couples may have up to three children
major
policy shift from the existing limit of
two after recent data showed a dramatic
decline in births
in the world's most populous country
beijing scraped its decade old one child
policy in 2016 replacing it with two
child
limit that failed to trigger or sustain
surgeon birds experts say the main
barrier to have children in china is the
high cost of raising kids in a poll
uh the weibo account of the official
state-run press
press agency asking are you ready for
the three-child policy
about 29 000 of the 31 000 responders
said they would never
think of it while the remainder would
choose among the options i've
uh i'm ready and very eager to do so
it's on my agenda
i'm hesitating and there's a lot to
consider the poll was later removed
fines of twenty thousand dollars were
given
imposed on people for having a third
child as
late of last year twenty thousand four
hundred forty dollars if you have a
third child yeah this
thing about this just shows the the
nerve of the chinese government
but doesn't it inspire you say i just
want to move to china oh my god the
chinese dream because you don't have to
think they'll just tell you what to do
at every every step of the way
you know uh it is an issue you know
they're declining birth rate i mean if
the chinese government is this
interested in it they are worried about
it but
you know when when you research this
story you realize these young people
don't want to have kids it's way too
damn expensive in china
and they're serious about that and you
know what else they don't want to do
they don't want to work as many hours as
they used to
that 996 thing that was popular in china
with jack ma
and everything they don't feel like
there's any payoff to that anymore if
you got in the beginning of the tech
industry and you could really cash in on
that they were all in but
they they're they're pushing back on
that they're definitely pushing back on
the kids i think a lot of them don't
even want to have one
they don't have time to raise one child
so
it's nice to see you know the
non-compliance of the chinese people and
just tell them to shove it
well you know it's not it's not an issue
that that's endemic to china either i
mean that's an issue for the communists
in brooklyn and
los angeles as well it just goes to for
me to show
how little regard for humanity the
baseline of humanity that
communists really have they see
everything as a spreadsheet they see
everything as a number
uh it scares me a little bit that china
wants to ramp up its population because
i think they're prepping for war
and they want to have they want to have
some more people ready
to uh to to storm the shores if you will
but um yeah the uh the the the concept
by the way of the one child
um we don't talk about in our country
enough and again we we talked about this
the last time i was on with
lebron james and john cena and all of
our repentant rich
who who carry water for for the ccp
every chance that they get
and this is what what they do this this
is what they're co-signing on
what they're co-signing on is social
engineering what they're call signing on
is cultural hegemony
and it it's it's an embarrassing thing
for us as a society to say
well i want to have a really popular
movie so i guess it's okay that this
woman had a second child and they put
the baby in a basket down the river
because they didn't want to find like i
mean it's insane well
the cool thing is dr fauci is going to
help them out he said whatever you guys
need i'm behind you 100
we'll support this five kids i'm there
well let me tell you one thing that this
this makes me think about here's what it
makes me think about
you know what's the one country that's
got the
youngest population in the world what do
you think is the one country india
india 54 of india's populations below 25
years old let me say this one more time
54 percent tom that's a big number 54
is you know how we have to baby boom
then we have the millennials the gen x
whatever
all these big booms 76 million baby
boomers 78 million in all these things
you talk about 54 below 25 years old who
do you think they're thinking about what
do you think china's thinking about
china's sitting there saying wait a
minute we've had the biggest population
for a long time
india's about to pass them up that's
number one that's going to happen next
you know decade or so when you pass them
up in population maybe it's going to
take a couple decades but they're going
to pass them out the way they're going
and they're sitting there saying if
those guys have a younger audience
younger talent pool that means
innovation is going to be higher
creativity is going to be higher the
energy to less is going to be higher
stamina is going to be higher
competition the willingness to compete
is going to be higher cost of labor
lower
everything is going to be higher for
india that gives them an edge
i don't know if they're sitting there in
the room and they're saying well let's
do this because
folks want to have more kids let's just
be noble and let's
let's let people have what they want
yeah i don't think that's the case
isn't that a problem though like i mean
have we gone i mean i don't i don't want
to
i don't want to take up you know the
reigns as the as the progressive here at
the table but
haven't we gone too far where we're
starting to talk about you know the cost
of raising a child outside of the
benefit like how much it costs we're
like
our entire job as humans is to move this
thing forward well truth but if you have
kids you're reminded of how expensive
they are
every average i mean he told me
yesterday with his kids when he pays to
go to his kids for school and i was like
this is insanity i mean
it can't once you have kids that's not
average you don't make a decision based
on money but you can't help but think
about it
but then it's idiocracy then it's just
that idiocracy goes from a movie to a
documentary then you just have dumb poor
people having more kids
no will skew a little bit because you
won't look at it so scientifically
i'm looking at it as what do you think
of a societal issue no i think it's a
fact that's all it is but i don't think
you
well you know what i think people do use
that fact and realize okay i think i
might be done now right
because i know the cost of the kids it
doesn't affect how you raise them or how
you feel about nothing like that
yeah but i mean you do see there's it's
a lot of money to raise kids and it's
even more interesting
million per from zero to eighteen years
in a lot of cases it's a lot higher
right so that's absolutely
quarter million okay let me play devil's
advocate you're working anyway you're
earning anyway
what what else would you spend the money
on that would be more beneficial to you
and society
than raising a kid that has your core
values
we're not arguing against that i don't
think that's i will tell you though i
will
i'll get i'll i'll tell you the opposite
side i also think
there are some families that ought to
not have as many kids as they have i i
also think the current tax system uh
unfortunately influences some people to
have a lot of kids and take the benefits
and the welfare and the
payments that are being sent from the
government because if you have nine kids
you're making 400 per and you're getting
you know all these other benefits that
comes with it that's a salary to you
that's been paid out so the tax system
kind of favors people having a lot of
kids
i'm not for let's go have a lot of kids
i'm not
four let's not have l have any kids i'm
for
hey you think you can afford three kids
go ahead what works for you you don't
want to have any i have friends
that say i have a friend i have a very
we were born a month apart me and this
other friend of mine okay
were born a month apart him and his wife
and his parents are convinced the worst
thing they can do is have kids right now
well he's lucky he married her then
because they have the same belief both
of them
don't want to have any kids they're he's
in his uh early 40s like me she's in her
interesting and she hasn't flipped at
all and and the grandparents
are happy like meaning their parents
have no influence to say hey you gotta
have their middle eastern it's like you
would at least say and
his parents only had one kid it's a
one-sided so they're not in the mindset
of i know a lot of people today that
don't
have kids but i think if you have the
money and you want to be able to
you know leave a legacy beyond i think
you ought to have as many kids as you
can
this should be a meme this should be a
meme for how expensive kids are i was
watching shark tank one time and this
guy
walks into the tank right with all that
vigor and excitement they come through
the doors
he's fired up he's ready to give his
pitch tells the sharks he's got
eight kids eight kids right so he does
the thing he's trying to get the
investment yeah
shut out by everybody walks out no money
you should have seen the walk of shame
as he left that room knowing i got eight
kids and i didn't get that investment
i'm screwed he says
no you just keep little yeah you just
sent it the other point with india too
though if you have 54
of the country that is 2025 think of the
tax revenue from these
from this generation they're going to be
able to build themselves up a lot
quicker
listen i am so excited about india
this is the i've never i went to india
you know the story two three years ago
we went to india we went to mumbai and i
spoke at iit with the chairwoman of uh
state bank of india you know 240 000
employees
the desire to want to learn about
business and
entrepreneurship is insane you know how
i finished my message when i uh
spoke at in in india here's my message
yeah you actually got to watch what i
say at the end
my last 10 minutes was the following
here's what i said i said listen
students because there's politicians in
the room there's billionaires in the
room there's
government employees i said this is my
biggest recommendation to you india
right now you're hungry right now you
want to be like
america you want to compete against
america china i said the next
decade or two you're going to make so
much money
your country is going to become so rich
they're going to be able to create some
of the most incredible inventions that
the world's going to use
and then they're going to try to raise
taxes don't vote for it
they're going to i'm telling you in 20
years do not vote for
raising taxes i'm telling you it's
coming right just say no yep and
everybody starts laughing and you see
the politicians go like this
and i said thank you so much for my time
i don't know you're my god the way you
describe india sounds to me
a lot there seems to be a lot of
parallels or at least you believe there
to be a lot of parallels
to india and postwar japan you think
they're they're about to go through
a phase of industrialization that's
going to bring them out of the third
world
and then into the fortunate even more i
believe even more i believe you know the
by the way japan right now is the
country with the most
that uh their debt ratio today in india
it's it's a scare they're number one
above everybody okay then they have less
than ten percent of the population of
india too
it's it's a scary thought what's going
on but you gotta innovation
auto so many different industries they
crossed seventies eighties and nineties
absolutely they came in u.s and they
were one the best things that they
raised taxes
and then they raised taxes so the thing
with india here's the thing with india
in business when i left valley total
fitness
and i went to bali's and my boss robbie
told me if you do xyz
you're going to be able to leave
chatsworth the gym i didn't want to be
in are you going to be able to go to
hollywood and be the weekend manager
i said who do i have to be he said edwin
guerra
i beat edwin guerra in a smaller club he
said if you beat him you got the job
in sales in sales i beat edwin guerra i
was ranked number eight edwin
was number 10. he comes and says i have
to have a meeting with you i'm like i
know what he's meeting with i'm dressed
up nice i got my crease back in the days
i would crease my own
shirts i would crease everything right
so i'm coming in i'm like robby's here
come
meet with me he's going to give me the
goodness so patrick let's go send him
back hey buddy
someone tell you great job last month
phenomenal job i'm so proud of the way
you're going right now wonder you're
going to be a supervisor at bali's
and but i need you to stay here because
no one's been able to turn this club
around more than you
and we need you here and i said i'm
sorry
you told me to beat edwin garrison i
said did you see the leaders bulletin
let me show it
like this he says no i've seen it
already i said that's my job he says
look he's been here and i'm giving a job
tim said wait a minute wait what
i'm giving a job to him he gives the job
to him i said why to him he says
tenure he's been here with us for six
years you've been here for us with us
nine months
you know what i said and i said i quit
that moment by the way i can't quit
yeah i don't i'm like i don't know what
i'm used to the job i quit
don't leave jobs they leave bosses
here's what's crazy robbie robbie helped
me get very good in sales and he's
actually a very good
guy but that decision where they came
from him or from a guy above him it is
what it is here's the point i'm trying
to make
the point i'm trying to make is bali's
equals india today
india needs some laws india needs some
strong
law schools india needs to have some uh
what do you call it some level of
confidence to give where a smaller
person who's coming up to be able to
compete
they can't be bullied by the big guy
there's still a lot of corruption going
on in india
if you ask the small entrepreneur that's
coming up what their biggest fear is
there's a level of corruption taking
place there if they if they can fix that
yeah
where there's trust in the system and i
can compete fairly
and if i lose i lose then there's going
to be some good innovation taking place
what's the plan there because
sound this sounds almost exactly what
china has in mind for
africa especially south africa so guess
what's the youngest country in the world
top 10 youngest countries in the world
i'm going to say south africa it's all
africa
really top 10. yeah so look what china
is doing china's going over investing
all that money to compete we need to
compete on that continent in ways that
we are not competing that silk road is
going to change the youngest
top 10 is that because of the mortality
in africa people die old
are younger so then the the people are
younger there's plenty of old people
good point maybe
good point anyway hey the thing that
scares me a little bit about india
though is the level of poverty
kind of festering before an opportunity
for socialism to come in there
so that's what scares me because there
are there really is a huge discrepancy
in that country but you know i'm
surprised they haven't evolved a little
bit more athletically
in sports haven't become a little bit
more of a world power with that type of
population
in american sports they're not good but
in uh what would that
in eastern sports they do pretty well
they do pretty well with cricket it just
hasn't been a priority
well we'll see what's gonna happen here
all i know is folks in china are
probably making babies right now so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye